somebody in our group chat knows this
guy who did this and he shared a text
message that the guy sent before he did
it so he goes
um he goes yo bro and the person says
what's up he goes are you doing anything
in the next hour want to help me pull
off a stunt I'm at the gym and I need a
box LOL I'm gonna walk out in front of
the Twitter office with a box in my hand
there's hella TV Crews outside
[Laughter]
[Music]
so Elon takes over Twitter I guess the
purchase went through I feel like there
was never like confirmation like he
actually wired them on he just literally
showed up the office and like yeah there
there hasn't been like a proper ribber
ribbing ribbing ribbon-cutting moment
like it's not like a squatter you just
like went into the office and they're
like you own it now oh you seem to be
here yeah it's mine
playground rules like wow that's all it
took to have Twitter
have you ever heard of uh like a coup
like a coup d'etat like with governments
uh you know I was I I read a lot of yeah
they're pretty cool yeah they are I read
a lot of history history jokes or
history jokes I read a lot of history
books about uh whatever and they talk
about like a coup and I'm like
so you literally just like walked into
the White House and you just said like
you know this is mine and like the
general has promised me that he's going
to convince these soldiers to attack you
know what I mean it's like an
interesting concept you're like so it's
all just made up I guess like these
rules that we're we we live by this is
just this is fiction and that's kind of
like what I felt like he did he just
walked he's like well I I own this now
thank you have you seen uh you know
Derek Lewis the UFC fighter have you
seen that compilation of his thing where
he says just get up
no so they're like Derek uh you're big
like knockout artist but like you know
the the knock on your's always been like
what if you get a wrestling thing you
know how's your Jiu Jitsu or your
training
digital ain't real man and they're like
what he's like man you don't need Jiu
Jitsu just get up
and they're like he's like why I don't
want to stay on the ground with another
man between my legs no I'm not into that
like I'm not gonna do so I'm just gonna
get up they're like but you you need Jiu
Jitsu to get up he's like I'm just gonna
get up and so then there's a clip of him
saying that and then there's a it's like
a six minute compilation of literally
somebody takes him down he doesn't he
just stands
so powerful that's how I feel that's
what Elon Musk did he's like nah just
just walk in yeah what do you mean he's
like well I'm just gonna walk in with a
sink
and take it so anyway he does this thing
where he just he says this is mine and
there's all these reporters outside of
Twitter's office and something amazing
for a story they're waiting for the
story about something going wrong Elon
comes here oh there's a protest there's
a walk and so
what happens is the first big story that
happens is there's a picture of these
two guys and uh kind of like you know
kind of like nerdy sort of engineering
looking guys and they're holding giant
cardboard boxes and it says these two
data scientists the data Engineers data
scientists were fired today from Twitter
here they're seen walking out with their
possessions in their boxes and um and I
saw it and immediately something looked
a little off
because I was like this guy just looks
so goofy but I was like man that's
pretty believable you know there's a
bunch of goofy looking people are
working Tech but okay oh my God he looks
wild man they really found the perfect
character he looks pretty goofy and then
I read the name and it says but he but
he but he had a box in his hand so he
each had a brown box like which is just
foreign because like if you work at a
tech company like you you don't even
probably own anything you own enough
just to put in a book put your laptop in
your backpack and like if you do get
fired do they even like is that a thing
where you like hand people a box anymore
I don't know what I mean they played it
perfectly so then it says Rahul ligma
and something Johnson uh Daniel Johnson
were fired today blah blah and then and
I saw that and I was like oh my God this
guy executed a ligman like for those who
don't know
ligma is a is a little joke that people
play on the internet where it's like
like you say something about ligma and
then something's like ligma what's like
I'm not familiar link my nuts right so
that's the joke and they did this to
basically I think CNBC was the first one
who like reported it and then it just
kept getting the same photo kept getting
spread ever because everybody wanted
this story about and the leadership
she was this CNBC reporter and I I the
original tweet said something like uh
we're at the scene of Twitter these two
Engineers just came out who said they
were the first to be laid off and it's
just so clear how defeated they are and
like there's like an audible or what
does she say she's like there's just a
visible uh they're just visibly defeated
and totally broken and Rahul ligma says
now he has no idea how he's going to be
able to afford his Tesla payments
and then he's sitting there holding a
Michelle Obama book and so it's like him
with his box just holding this Michelle
Obama book I don't know why and he just
said it and she tweeted out like you
know this is just they say the first of
many that's going to happen it was just
like a crazy crazy scene so people are
um people are are have heard this part
of the story but now we got that my
first million exclusive juice on top of
it so somebody in our group chat knows
this guy who did this and he shared a
text message that the guy sent before he
did it so he goes
um he goes yo bro and the person says
sup he goes are you doing anything in
the next hour want to help me pull off a
stunt I'm at the gym and I need a box
LOL I'm gonna walk out in front of the
Twitter office with a box in my hand
there's hella TV Crews outside
and then this is literally how he pulled
this up and he just goes he gets an
empty box and a Michelle Obama book
there's nothing else in the box and we
watch out in the TV Crews go for it and
so so that was I thought amazing and
then he so that was like I mean what
kind of Genius is this person then he
goes
all right there's hella TV Crews let's
go get him there he goes he goes bro the
media is so dumb I literally put five
minutes of planning into this even my
uncle in India has seen the picture now
he goes he goes the first thing is did
you just see the cameras and just walk
out there he goes yeah basically I got
to the gym it's near Twitter's
headquarters I saw all these cameras and
so I just went and did it
amazing that is so funny the better who
is this guy he's like a founder of like
a tech startup basically he just did
this before Oh my God yeah I am ready to
invest and his thing says like stealth
startups I'm like I'm ready to invest in
whatever he's doing anything on TV
there's hella TV cameras name your price
ligma
so so he goes okay so that was him did
you see the interview with the other guy
Daniel Johnson no he also had a little
gym so his was on videos that they're
like you know um how do you feel about
this today he's like I don't know I just
gotta like I gotta go home I gotta talk
to my husband and wife and regroup
[Laughter]
did anyone comment on that the news
didn't even like be like they just
played the clip and then I saw that I
was like wow that is the funniest thing
I've ever heard perfect timing and these
guys are like you know comedic Geniuses
basically so yeah this is pretty gold
amazingly well played
um yeah do you want to talk about the
Elon war room like what he's actually
doing in there like do you want to talk
about that or not really have your phone
not really I mean like I I read that he
said like hey guys you have a week to
get this one thing done and I think that
that's cool that's that's a good way to
run things I'm nervous he's gonna screw
it all up and because I make money from
Twitter so like I don't want it to go
away uh but uh of course chill bro yeah
yeah
I got Consulting calls to take so
um I don't really care though like when
he talks about this [__] I'm like this
doesn't impact me that much I don't I
don't care what you're gonna do well I
just want I don't care it's not going to
impact me but I do find it interesting
how he's going about this so basically
the report is he goes in and the first
report I thought again was another troll
but I guess this is real do you see this
he's like he told every engineer to
print out all the code that they've
committed and they've written in the
last three or six months and have it
ready for review did you see this why
print so you can just see the the page
link those and then they change their
mind like I guess they realize how bad
of an idea that was and like you know an
hour later they're like uh Shred the
papers actually we're gonna review on
the computer just be prepared to review
and so people are like all these
Engineers like I printed out like you
know 300 pages of code so I guess I'll
just thread this I don't know what's
going on here dude and what's crazy is
like if you go to businessinsider.com
the headline is like you know I think it
says like the toil of working at Twitter
and it's like painting it like these
people here's there yeah this like this
is what it's like to toil Elon musk's
Twitter the expectation is literally to
work 24 7. and is that really I think
that that's I swear to God straight
clown Behavior I cannot believe they're
doing that I can believe it uh and it
says this is it one of the people
familiar said describing the feeling of
the company under musk your job is on
the line it's like dude your job's
always on the line uh like is it you
know like this is it like it's not your
right to work at Twitter you dumbass uh
but I I uh I I thought it was funny
because like come on man like you're
you're coding this yeah you're gonna
have to work 50 hours maybe for a little
while but also I think a lot of
employees at Twitter are probably like
this is awesome we've been sitting on
our ass let's let's do it and that side
doesn't seem to be getting covered a lot
yeah and so he created I guess a war
room so he basically brought in a bunch
of people he trust so he brought in
people from his other companies like he
brought in his chief legal person that
guy's now like the general counsel
basically he brought in he created a war
room and now here's who's reported to be
in the war room it's uh Elon his uh his
his chief counsel then it's Jason
calacanus
oh and then I think Jason's Jason's
amazing but like what the hell does he
know yeah I guess uh sriram from a16z so
just venture capitalist who's a former
PM who used to work at Twitter is also
you know how to run at Twitter
um and Clubhouse and uh
Snapchat yeah and then also
um I guess like some other people some
Engineers or people from uh like boring
company or neural link or whatever like
some people he trust like his cousin is
there like and they basically just set
up shop and they were like all right
what we're gonna do with this thing and
they're like change the logged out page
it forces you to sign up now you should
be able to read tweets before you sign
in you know you sign up and then which
is like an experiment's been tried many
times before and there's like um you
know we need to have this verification
program you have five days to deliver
this I guess and so there's like sort of
uh trying to figure this out of you know
who stays who goes what are we building
how are we going to turn this thing
around and um
fascinating I wish I could be a fly on
the wall in this uh in this war room I
think that would be like probably the
most interesting thing to do right now
I think it would be awesome
um I hope they don't screw it up though
because I got some [__] courses I
gotta sell so don't screw it up
my point of view has always been very
simple which is all the things he
complains about are things that like
power users would be annoyed at on
Twitter like the Bots problem or
um you know verification or the
algorithm you know like not serving me
the tweets I want like the problem is
that just only I don't know whatever
like 300 million people use Twitter and
it's like you know five times smaller
than like the other big social services
and it doesn't really grow that much and
like
it's not like you know my mom doesn't
use Twitter because she's like oh
there's too many Bots if I tweet about
crypto that will tell me to buy crypto
that's not her problem she just doesn't
see value in it and like you know he
just says I don't get it yeah I don't
get it I I don't know why I would need
this like you know I don't I don't need
to check this whereas Instagram and
WhatsApp and like Snapchat have all
given her a reason that she needs to
have it like she needs to have Snapchat
if she wants to see more pictures of her
kids she needs to have Instagram if she
wants to keep up with what's going on
with like Bollywood or whatever right
like you know everybody finds a need in
the service and like that's the core
problem with Twitter is that the core
needed addresses is only for like people
like us and like it doesn't address the
need for a whole bunch of other people
on the planet and if they wanted it to
be more valuable then they would need to
do that
foreign
[Music]